Okay.
Let's talk about the rapidly growing rift
between former Democratic presidential candidate
Bernie Sanders and his own supporters.
The same Bernie supporters who have praised
Bernie for saying he's been saying the same
thing for 40 years.
He's.
Assistant He doesn't sell out.
He always tells you what you think he doesn't
bout a corporate interest.
He doesn't bout a party politics, all of the
stuff.
A lot of Bernie's supporters are now saying
he sold out by saying Support Biden.
He's sold out.
He's nearly 80 years old.
What exactly does selling out mean for Bernie
Sanders at this point in time?
What is he trying to position himself for
by selling out?
Bernie said yesterday that it would be irresponsible
for his supporters not to vote for Joe Biden
in November.
And a ton of Bernie supporters are absolutely
furious.
For some reason, they're tweeting at me on
Twitter.
I don't know why that's going on, but it is
this is all from an interview that Bernie
did with the Associated Press, and it is getting
very ugly.
Bernie was asked about the choice that his
supporters now have to make.
And Bernie Sanders said, quote, Do we be as
active as we can in electing Joe Biden and
doing everything we can to move Joe and his
campaign in a more progressive direction?
Or do we choose to sit it out and allow the
most dangerous president in modern American
history to get reelected?
I believe that it's irresponsible for anybody
to say, well, I disagree with Joe Biden.
I disagree with Joe Biden.
And therefore, I'm not going to be involved.
Bernie says that this is it.
Bernie says it's Joe Biden time.
He says, despite technically still being on
future primary ballots, Bernie will not be
advertising.
He won't be running ads.
He won't be spending money.
And that he is all in for Joe Biden and that
it would be irresponsible for his supporters
not to be.
So if you are a Bernie supporter, I'm trying
to figure out how you square praising Bernie
for never selling out.
Always speaking his mind, always being genuine
for 40 years, 40 years.
And then now at 78 years of age, Bernie has
become disingenuous and a tool of the Democratic
Party.
If that's really what you believe about Joe,
about Bernie Sanders right now, it's very
hard to imagine you had the right assessment
of him all along.
I believe the simpler explanation is Bernie
just gets it.
Bernie.
Much like Noam Chomsky, understand the importance
of removing Donald Trump.
Now, another source of controversy from the
same interview with the Associated Press is
that Bernie is being accused by some of attacking
his own supporters because he's sort of distanced
himself from a woman named Brianna joy.
Gray, who was his press secretary at one point
in time.
She posted on Twitter, quote, With the utmost
respect for Bernie Sanders, who is an incredible
human being and a genuine inspiration.
I don't endorse Joe Biden.
I supported Bernie because he backed ideas
like Medicare for all, canceling all student
debt and a wealth tax.
Biden supports none of those.
To me, this is the the, you know, just the
epitome of a misguided comment because, OK,
Biden's not for Medicare for all, but he wants
to expand it to 60 plus, which would give
it to 20 million more people.
Trump wants to kick it, 32 million people
off of health insurance.
Joe Biden just put out a plan for partial
cancelation of some student debt.
Trump now is being forced into suspending
some payments because of coronavirus.
But Biden's better than Trump on that on the
wealth tax.
OK.
Biden doesn't support Warren or Bernie's wealth
tax.
But Biden's tax plan and capital gains taxing
plan is way better than Donald Trump.
So to me, this is, you know, missing the forest
for the trees.
But in any case, Bernie was asked about the
comments from Brianna Joy Gray.
And he did a sort of Brianna who kind of thing
telling the Associated Press simply, she is
my former press secretary, not on the payroll,
which is kind of a funny copout because Bernie's
campaign confirmed no one's on the payroll.
Like in other words, the campaign is over.
And this reaction from Bernie about Brianna
is throwing a lot of people into total disarray
on Twitter.
Some people are saying Bernie is attacking
his supporters by saying this.
So once again, my goal going forward is I
don't want to split the left into factions.
I want to just bring the left together to
defeat Donald Trump.
All of the WOAK Twitter stuff is dividing
the left and it helps Trump.
So, first of all, my hope and instinct is
that the very loud Twitter read it online.
Bernie Biden stuff is overblown.
And that while it's very divisive on the Internet,
I'm hoping it's not that divisive in the real
world.
If the primary taught us one thing, it's that
the loud Bernie wing is very loud online.
But it didn't translate to that many voters.
Joe Biden is ahead of Bernie by nearly 3 million
votes right now.
And so in the same way, just because the group
is louder on Twitter doesn't mean they're
necessarily that many of them.
My hope is.
That outside of this Twitter area, there is
not really that much division among the left
and it's clear that we need to vote to remove
Donald Trump.
But what's going on here is simply that a
lot of people are just struggling with it.
Bernie realizes Trump is an existential threat
to the world and his handling of Corona virus
has proven that even more acutely.
In practice, you're either helping Trump's
Proteau fascist authoritarian baby dictatorship
or you're working against it.
It is true that if you don't vote, you're
not voting.
That's not literally a vote for Trump.
This idea of not voting is a vote for Trump.
No, it's not literally true.
But we've got to be adults by staying home.
Because you voted, Bernie, and you won't vote
Biden.
You are furthering Trump's Proteau fascist
authoritarian reelection if you're not activating
against it.
You are essentially one more vote for allowing
it.
And I can't do that.
There's no neutrality here.
Now, maybe you feel okay about having that
role because you're an acceleration ist and
you believe another four years of Trump will
more quickly destroy the system and lead to
it being rebuilt in a better sort of framework.
Okay, that's fine.
Let's just call things what they are, though.
Bernie is acting sensibly and normally here.
If you believe Bernie has been genuine for
the last 40 years to say now in April of 2020,
Bernie has become disingenuous.
Doesn't make sense.
We've got six and a half months to fight Trump
until we either get four more years of it
or we get something better.
Bernie is keeping his eye on the ball.
That's a good thing.
You would think that the trust he has built
with his supporters would have them saying,
you know, Bernie is probably right rather
than Bernie has sold out to the DNC, which
you don't believe he's done for 40 years.
Why would he do it now?
Let's think critically, guys.